first chop mozzarella into small cubes  then take handfuls of leftover risotto  add a cube of mozzarella and fold into a  ball around the cheese this dish is  perfect with leftover mushroom risotto  but is gray with any risotto for the  coating prep three balls one with flour  one with bread crumbs and one with  beaten egg dip each errand teeny first  into the flour then the egg wash and  finally the bread crumbs then in a pan  heat the olive oil and fry the arancini  until golden brown  drain and serve simply with lemon  easy arancini a delicious tempting treat  as great for leftovers and cooks in  under 10 minutes so it cools down even  more and then combined start mixing that  in it's reading three fingers while in  front to behind and this part of the  knuckle